hey how's it going brother this is Wow
and welcome to this show doesn't really
have a name yet does it so anyway we're
gonna go through five weird [ __ ] cool
[ __ ] Oh wine and stupid you both seem to
like this videos and I got a lot of
suggestions these are all suggested from
your breasts all these mixed purchases I
try and keep them kind of low-budget
the first one is probably my favorite
it's basically a pillow cover signed by
Nicolas Cage so now you can dream about
Nicolas Cage every time you go to bed
it's kind of big I feel like I'll I'll
use it as a blanket or something so me
and Nick can just snuggle up I thought I
bought two of these along and did buy
two of them you can never have too many
Nic Cage pillow covers this one is even
better because it says see you in my
dreams
absolutely beautiful great quality would
rate this product 5 Nick Cage out of
thanks product so you might have heard
of these again don't make out with Nick
Cage what are you doing dad what are you
doing - Nick Cage
oh I'm sorry peds just really like these
movies you know makes product I love
hair brushes especially pink ones but
haha it's not your hairbrush I mean it
is a hairbrush but god damn it how do I
so you thought selfie sticks were stupid
well you haven't seen selfie hair oh my
god so there we go
looking good there you are you look so
good I mean I was talking to myself
Kawai hmm this is probably the greatest
thing that's ever happened to mankind
I would rated zero out of ten it's
[ __ ] stupid piece of [ __ ] all right
let's get to the good stuff and yeah son
how much you another gift Edgar Oh what
is it your [ __ ] know what I hope this
one fits oh my god you're gonna look so
good
you look so good how's it work don't
worry my time but Jesus scared the [ __ ]
I mean he loves it for the final part
how the hell is this even gonna work
okay seat seat seats oh my god I'm
scared
yes oh my god he's so cool yes he loves
it oh my god is a raptor Jurassic Park
[Music]
again are you a raptor you're eating
yourself Edgar why do you do this this
is how he was supposed to look like by
the way I don't I don't think it worked
next up we have another useless item of
course which is inflatable ballerina
fancy dress costume now I am already
extremely fabulous in every way possible
if you ever want to be as fabulous as me
then this is your chance let's give it a
go what's up a nice you hang on tight
[Music]
- but not least this is from Japan and I
think it's candy sushi all the
instructions are in Japanese it's fine
I'm a genius
swedish master chef less studious so
this comes in this light package first
we're gonna make the rice oh it smell
it's really sweet yeah it does smell
aroma yeah
let's make sweet eggs sweet egg powder
oh it's yellow yeah yearning this money
is red how does it work
next up we have the seaweed it says
stretch it out until it's like long and
by mmm this one smells good mm-hmm
oh it's disgusting that looks mmm can't
wait to eat that we're thing hi when
they made this alright pretty good so
far huh and then we're gonna add the
Soliman on it alright there we go this
is my sushi I call him
causal Kim bang some yellow salt do what
it is oh my god you're cranking no let
me do it first no you should do it first
I'm scared
[Music]
no it's candy mutts he approves sushi
thank you all right
wasn't that amazing please leave a like
if you enjoyed this videos and let me
know so I can make more of them if
you're a company wants me to review your
[ __ ] email in the description maybe I'll
check it out but that's all for now
thank you for watching and that's always
stay awesome oh my god they have four
holes your prayers have been answered
and your stop playing with the dark away
to costume so awkward